was there a moment or maybe a specific
gig that you booked that finally made
you think you know i'm not just trying
i'm here and i'm doing it now
um i i sort of well when i got here i
definitely had that moment getting
here was a little trickier i um
i grew up in australia
thinking that i would want to come to
the states eventually
to try my hand in it and never really
thinking that
you know i would get as far as i've i've
come today and i've been super lucky um
but you know at the time growing up and
this is like
i don't know this is probably going to
be like a thing that a lot of people
connect with but i had a terrible
acne problem and i used to always think
i can't go
to the states with this acne problem
because i'll never get a job
having worked in australia and having
been rejected from a couple jobs because
of my skin problem at the time and so
obviously it's a it's it's a
it's like a you know obviously a
psychological thing to work through and
i remember that i was a group of people
of a group of friends and mine had
convinced me to come with them
and it was really only because of that
and then i
and i told my agent that i was wanting
to come here that i was encouraged
and had a support system and thought
okay
i'll give this a go and um and i did
so yeah that's that's crazy
it makes me mad that you kind of ran
into that problem because that's a very
difficult thing for a lot of kids to
experience out there even if it's just
you know amongst friends so the fact
that you were actually like
rejected from something for it just kind
of makes me fume
yeah i mean it's it's definitely uh
it's you know it goes into all that body
image conversation that we have and what
people deal with and how psychologically
scaring it is
and how you work through that you know
and ironically from for me my faith
is my is my job it's my tool it's my
it's what i use
predominantly in my craft and so yeah
it's just it's been an interesting
journey and not something that i really
ever
talk about but i think it is important
to talk about it because i know
so many people so many kids grapple with
this they go to school they don't
they don't know how to deal with it they
get teased for it and it's all kinds of
things you lose a job for it
you